les occidentaux je vous le disais tout à
l'heure se prépare à instaurer de
nouvelles sanctions contre la russie et
une multiplie aussi les annonces
d'expulsion deux diplomates russes 15
pour le danemark pour espionnage annoncé
ce matin 30 autres annoncées par
l'italie dans la foulée virginie hertz
bonjour ça a commencé hier et ça a
tendance à s'accélérer au fur et à
mesure que les heures passent oui
absolument alors on peut même parler de
la semaine dernière c'était la belgique
avait annoncé l'expulsion de 21
personnes soupçonnées je cite
d'implication dans des opérations
d'espionnage et d' influence menaçant la
sécurité nationale une expulsion qui
devait se faire dans les quinze jours à
venir elle avait été suivie par
l'irlande qui a expulsé elle quatre
diplomates qui ne correspondaient pas
aux standards internationaux du
comportement diplomatique ensuite les
pays bas eux annoncent qu'ils nous avons
expulsé dit cet officier de
renseignement russes qui s'adonnent
aussi secrètement à des activités
d'espionnage l'allemagne 40 personnes la
lituanie elle est beaucoup plus précise
elle parle d'une expulsion de
l'ambassadeur de russie en raison des
atrocités commises par les forces armées
russes dans diverses villes ukrainiennes
et est fait mention évidemment de la
ville de bitche à la france reste assez
vague elle danse et la motivation on
parle de l'expulsion de 35 diplomates
dont les activités sont contraires aux
intérêts de la france qu'on peut dire en
tout cas c'est que le compte de
l'ambassade de russie en france anticipe
lui même une fermeture et invite ses
followers ceux qui suivent ce conte de
continuer à les suivre sur télégramme
les ambassades qui sont des puissants
relais de la désinformation russe au
point que la vice président de la
commission européenne verra jour où va
parler de réseau de propagande et
demandé aux plateformes eau plate forme
twitter facebook notamment aux plates
formes des réseaux sociaux de mieux
contrôler tout ce tous les comptes de
ses ambassades la russie elle vient de
réagir le kremlin parle de manque de
clairvoyance européenne suite à toutes
ces expulsions et ses annonces et menace
de deux réponses de mesures symétrique
évidemment en cas de concrétisation de
ces annonces alors il ya évidemment ce
qu'on pense tout ce qui tout ce qui se
dit ici chez nous en europe et toute la
propagande russe également à l'oeuvre en
russie avec une des particulièrement mis
en avant ces derniers jours oui
absolument alors on a vu avec elena
volochine notre chef du bureau à moscou
comment les médias russe proche du
kremlin présenté cette guerre qui est
appelé en vo six opérations spéciales la
diabolisation de la population
ukrainienne les arguments autour de la
nécessité de des nazis fier le
gouvernement depuis dimanche on a
l'impression que cette pro gbagbo a pris
un tour nouveau alors moins à la
télévision que dans une tribune
particulièrement virulente dans l'
agence de presse ria novosti elle
s'intitule cette tribune que doit faire
la russie avec l'ukraine et il est
question de désuet créé n'élise et le
pays c'est à dire faire disparaître le
pays en tant qu'hôtel faire disparaître
sa langue sa culture en fait je reprend
rapidement les arguments de
l'éditorialiste indie les nazis en
ukraine s'est pas seulement le
gouvernement mais la population donc on
est à un cran au dessus il faut une
rééducation de masse il faut que les
listes soient liquidés il faut une
punition je cite massive de toutes
celles et ceux qui portent des armes que
ce soit des soldats ou encore la garde
nationale en conclusion c'est un pays
qui est nazi à la racine qui doit ne
plus exister et le problème on pourrait
se dire c'est un total délire qui n'a
pas particulièrement d'influencé mais
non il faut prendre ce genre de tribune
au sérieux parce que ça montre qu'on est
passé dans une forme de radicalité
supérieur et surtout à partir du moment
où des médias officiels déshumanise
l'adversaire on rentre dans une autre
logique déshumanisé l'adversaire c'est
finalement aussi justifier qu'on le
fasse disparaître et ce qui est
intéressant c'est que cette tribune a
été publiée dimanche au même moment où
les autorités russes disait nous n'avons
rien à voir avec ce qui s'est passé
abuja et dans les autres villes c'est
une mise en scène en parallèle on a
l'impression aussi que les autorités
russes préparent la population a
effectivement à ce qui est peut-être des
révélations autour de crimes de guerre
mais des crimes de guerre qui
visiblement sont justifiées d'après ces
autorités merci beaucoup virginia